hi there the 87 what can i say i did
some writing some more writing which had
corrected a link i did a bit more
reading on my ipad both sitting in my
chair comfortably and also while on my
stepper you know i have i have the wind
in my sails this is i feel that that the
three months has been tremendously
successful however well i do now in
conversations but you know i was at the
golf course i ran into mr. Jay and I
just feel more comfortable now I'm not
so worried that I won't understand what
he's saying and I speak to him he was
there with his wife and a friend and I'm
over the hump and it's a great feeling
and so I recommend that that you do in
your language running you've got to have
a period of intensity however long
you're gonna make it one month three
months six months and you get that
momentum you get that the wind behind
your sales and thereafter the midst of
it's a smoother journey it's a smoother
journey that's where I am so I feel very
good about mercury and I know that while
I can't say that I'm a fluent speaker of
Korean I know that I can become I know
that I can become a fluent speaker of
Korea someone who can speak to Koreans
about a wide variety of subjects so I'm
happy so I recommend you do the same I
like to talk about history